[Musica]
allora stare qua su un palco all'interno
di questo cerchio rosso
illuminata da queste luci con tutti
questi occhi che mi guardano devo dire
che per me non è assolutamente semplice
sono una persona timida e ho scelto il
montaggio anche per questo perché mi ha
sempre permesso di stare nella mia
confort son che è appunto una sala di
montaggio
lontano quindi dalla vita caotica ed
emozionante del set cinematografico
e oggi come tante altre volte nella mia
vita ho pensato che sarebbe bello usare
il montaggio nella vita reale no perché
avrei sicuramente potuto post produrre
questo mio discorso
togliendo gli errori le imperfezioni le
mie esitazioni e avrei potuto offrirvi
un discorso fluido chiaro ed efficace
però forse al di là del fatto che non è
possibile
avremo un po perso
l'emozione del momento e anche
appunto questa voce che trema
ed enfatizzare con la persona che sta
parlando quindi oggi proverò a fare
questo discorso live
ma cos'è che fa di così interessante un
montatore noi in fondo passa tutta la
sua giornata davanti a uno schermo del
computer
questa è una timeline ovvero il piano di
lavoro di un montatore qualsiasi e può
essere un po visto anche questo questa
immagine come un corpo creato da
frankestein perché non è altro che è
l'assemblaggio di elementi diversi ad
esempio vediamo le musiche che sono
tutte quelle parti in giallo in basso
poi ci sono le parole le parti verdoline
e poi ci sono le immagini tutte quelle
parti azzurre e quindi se ci pensate
bene un po le emozioni che noi proviamo
al cinema derivano in fondo da questo
mostro e quando noi guardiamo un film
è sempre chiara secondo me l'idea
artistica di un regista così come è
chiaro magari il lavoro che fa un
direttore della fotografia grazie alle
luci che utilizza la pasta delle
immagini ma anche ai movimenti di camera
e può essere ben evidente anche il
lavoro che fa un attore quando si mette
in scena utilizza il proprio corpo per
esprimere delle sensazioni però il
montaggio per uno spettatore è
difficilmente percepibile e quando io ho
pensato al montaggio mi sono venuto in
mente alcune parole la prima è
senz'altro la parola invisibile perché
appunto il montaggio in parte deve
essere invisibile cioè io non lo
spettatore non deve percepire il taglio
non deve percepire che la relazione è
stata la continuità della relazione è
stata interrotta e quindi il suo lavoro
ahimé è un po inosservato
un'altra parola che mi fa pensare al
montaggio è sicuramente la parola intimo
perché lo spazio di lavoro di questa
fase è uno spazio solitario riflessivo
piccolo ben lontano dalle luci del set
cinematografico e intima e anche la
relazione che si instaura ad esempio tra
un regista e un montatore perché il
montatore deve essere bravo a cogliere
l'idea artistica del regista e ad
avvicinarsi il più possibile con il
proprio lavoro all'idea del film al film
che il regista vivente aveva in testa e
in fondo intima e anche la relazione che
si instaura tra il montatore e le
immagini stesse perché basta pensare a
tutto il tempo che un montatore passa
davanti alle immagini e infine una
parola l'ultima parola che mi è venuta
in mente la parola intuizione perché
almeno per quanto mi riguarda questo
processo creativo che avviene nel nel
montaggio è un po frutto dall'intuizione
cioè non c'è una regola che dica quanto
un'immagine deve stare sulla deve durare
ma in qualche modo cioè io non so io non
so mai prima di mettermi sulla timeline
il tipo di film che uscirà fuori e
quindi per me è molto intuitivo e
istintivo questo processo perché io
provo sperimento a costo le immagini e
improvvisamente io senta un certo punto
che la sequenza funziona quando mi sono
avvicinata al mondo delle arti visive
per me è stato naturale scegliere il
montaggio proprio per queste
caratteristiche
cioè io essendo una persona timida che
non ama stare esposta magari o sotto le
luci del come un regista ho scelto il
montaggio perché il montaggio mi ha
sempre permesso di sperimentare ma anche
di sbagliare perché questa questa cosa
sul set non è concessa e quindi ho
scelto di
venire qui oggi perché ho pensato anche
che proprio perché il montaggio spesso
non viene considerato come dovrebbe
è importante secondo me parlarne far
capire quanto in realtà sia affascinante
e quanto potere abbia il montaggio
all'interno della della creazione di un
film dopo la laurea allo iulm ho seguito
un corso agli a tele varun di parigi che
si intitolava
montaggio la scrittura del documentario
e il fatto che si utilizza si utilizzi
la parola si accosti la parola scrittura
viaggio ci deve far capire quanto in
realtà durante il montaggio c'è una
sorta di riscrittura del film ed è assai
importante e durante questo corso che
per c'è stato fatto fare un esercizio
che per me è stato davvero illuminante è
determinante nella scelta che poi ho
fatto di fare questa professione ovvero
ci hanno diviso in sei gruppi e
akita ciascun gruppo hanno dato lo
stesso materiale girato non ce la farò
un regista che in qualche modo ha
guidato la visione di questo
girato e dopo tre giorni ci siamo
ritrovati a guardare il lavoro di ognuno
e quello che io ho visto erano sei film
completamente diversi ma non erano
sfumature cioè dei cambi di piano erano
proprio sei film totalmente diversi cioè
si passava dal documentario alla
finzione alla videoarte e quindi questo
mi ha fatto capire quanto in realtà io
da montatrice potessi di dire la mia e
contribuire a creare qualcosa che non
era solo del regista che non era solo
della troupe ma potesse anche essere in
qualche modo mio mi ha anche se arrivavo
alla fine di tutto e io ho voluto fare
anche un esercizio proprio per farvi
rendere in maniera evidente questo
concetto ovvero appreso delle immagini
da stock qualsiasi e ho provato a
montarle sempre in maniera diversa non
avevano qui anche qui in questo caso non
c'era un regista che mi guidava quindi
mi sono lasciato trasportare da quello
che le immagini mi trasmettevano
primo esempio
[Musica]
allora in questo primo caso non mi sono
lasciata diciamo mi sono mi sono
divertita con le immagini non c'è una
linea narrativa il montaggio quale
dichiarato e sincopato segue un po il
ritmo della musica ho giocato anche con
le immagini sdoppiando le mettendo degli
effetti visivi quindi risultato potrebbe
essere un videoclip un video che vai sui
social però cosa succede se io adesso a
queste stesse immagini applico ad
esempio una voce
secondo contributo
[Musica]
nato
la torre incompreso
separato annunci finché non proprio
[Musica]
e poco mossi se d'estate abbiamo molti
minuto non succeda più
inglese
identiche di ci stanno decisivi di piave
uscendo da usare
così
come scritto
in questo caso a guidarmi sono state le
parole e vedete proprio come cambia
totalmente il tono del film perché
intanto si fa c'è una narrazione
lo spettatore si immedesima nel
protagonista e lo vedo in maniera
diversa
il tono è rilassato e sospeso e e anche
le immagini acquistano un diverso una
diversa percezione nello spettatore cioè
il fatto di accostare ad esempio la
parola paura
l'immagine del protagonista che sta per
saltare ti fa veramente percepire che
forse quel momento lì a un momento
particolare e delicato per chi fa
parkour quindi in questo caso potremmo
potrebbe benissimo essere la essere una
sorta di documentario un inizio di
documentare sul parkour vediamo l'ultimo
esempio
[Musica]
quale atmosfera e data assolutamente
dalla musica dagli effetti sonori ma
anche dalla color ed è questa ed è
questa atmosfera che mi ha guidata anche
nel montaggio perché se ci fate caso ho
scelto tutti quei momenti in cui il
protagonista non è visibile quindi a
crescere questo senso di inquietudine
come se lui volesse scappare o fuggire
da un pericolo e in questo caso qua
questo film questo potrebbe essere
magari un trailer di un corto di
finzione quindi riassumendo chi è
veramente il montatore può essere
considerato
un protagonista secondaria all'interno
della creazione di un film
io penso proprio di no nel senso che il
montatore ha una grande responsabilità
cioè quella di raccogliere il lavoro di
tutti in primis quello del regista e
cercare di dare forma a delle emozioni e
quindi ha tante sfaccettature perché il
montatore può essere visto un po come un
tessitore che intreccia i fili e il modo
in cui sceglie di intrecciarli da vita
di infinite possibilità però il
montatore anche un po come un meccanico
che ripara quelli che sono stati gli
inconvenienti sul 7 infatti tante volte
si dice vabbè la risolviamo in post
produzione e infine il montatore come
abbiamo visto per frankestein può essere
un po come un chirurgo che incide e
sutura le immagini però io credo che
alla fine il montaggio si ricorda
soprattutto una cosa cioè che a
differenza che nella vita reale dove il
taglio è sinonimo di ferita e cicatrice
al cinema il cut è un taglio costruttivo
cioè si taglia per unire per unire e
dare forma alle emozioni e quindi penso
che sia proprio questo il senso del mio
lavoro ma soprattutto il senso del
montaggio al cinema grazie
[Applauso]